there are 42 different wand Handles in
Hogwarts Legacy and they're split into
14 categories so all of these names you
see on screen right now there are three
different color variations within each
of those categories you see in Hogwarts
Legacy you can customize your wand and
there are two ways of doing it the first
way is when you initially get your wand
at ollivanders and once you set this it
cannot be changed we'll go over that
here in a second but the wand handles
you see here are an additional component
to your wand in Hogwarts Legacy in fact
the wand you receive from ollivanders
actually won't have a handle initially
at all so you'll need to collect one of
the 42 available Handles in the game and
then equip it from the gear menu this
allows customization of your wand as a
wizard or witch but it keeps the actual
core part of the wand the same and
unchangeable which certainly fits within
the lore of The Wizarding World now the
majority of these wand handles are going
to be available as random loot
throughout the vast world of Hogwarts
Legacy but five of them are actually
available through specific quests and
those five are the black variant of the
arrow avian gray orbicular Violet
checkerboard Brown and column beige I'll
also go ahead and put the quest on
screen now that you need to complete in
order to obtain each of these handles
one of the great things about Hogwarts
legacy's Quest system is that none of
these are missable quests you can get
them at any point in the game in fact I
got most of mine actually after beating
the game's main story now if you look
through your list of quests and you
don't have these then you may need to
pull out your map and scan through
looking for Quest icons and don't worry
I actually had a little moment of panic
myself thinking that they actually were
missable somehow but when I scan through
the map I eventually found them and they
do show the rewards right when you hover
over the quest so you really don't even
have to pay attention to the name of the
quest you can simply look at the rewards
instead as for the other wand handles
they're all under the exploration
category which means they could be
anywhere in the open world of Hogwarts
Legacy inside any loot chest I've been
looking around online I've seen a few
mentions from other sites where they
list out specific locations for a
specific wand handle and hopefully this
is true personally I have not been able
to replicate this from what I've seen
they appear to be randomized it'd be a
lot easier if you knew exactly where to
go for certain one handles but that
certainly does not fit with the way the
loot system works at least in the rest
of the game so I am pretty sure that
they are totally randomized if I'm wrong
let me know in the comments below which
I know you guys will now remember you
can actually change these wand handles
anytime and as many times as you want
once you have them they're totally yours
to use take them off reapply swap back
and forth as much as you want now as for
when you initially select your wand at
ollivanders you cannot go back and
change that so let's go over all of
those options and you'll actually go to
ollivanders pretty early in the game
most likely after your first hour so of
play time maybe some of you are
preparing for a second playthrough
already I actually think it's good to
take a look at the one handles first
because then when you're doing this
section with olive Ander you can
actually find one that is going to match
up even better because there are
definitely certain pairings that I think
just fit together better than others but
as for the one ceremony at ollivanders
if you've already linked your Wizarding
World account to your WB account it will
pull all of your wand information there
from The Wizarding World site into the
game but either way you can completely
change things here however you want now
the first tab is really a summary of
your selections and lists out the wood
type core type flexibility and wand
length what's interesting is that the
wood type doesn't really affect the
appearance of the wand at all and
neither does the one core for that
matter they also don't affect anything
about how the wand actually performs so
a few of these options are really here
just to honor the lore of the series
although I will say Mr ollivander's
dialogue does change slightly based on
the wand core you select and you should
find no more dependable a wand than one
with a unicorn hair core the second tab
is where you'll select your wand style
and this is really what controls the
main visual of the appearance of the
wand that you're going to be seeing in
game there are eight total Styles here
and each has three different variations
so you can go for the very simple
classic look with traditional colors or
you can go for something more unique
like a notched wand with a Dusty pink
coloration the next tab overs where
you'll set the wood type length and
flexibility and from what I was able to
see in my testing this is really just
here for the lore I didn't notice any
changes at all in the appearance of the
wand regardless of wood type flexibility
or even the link that was selected now
maybe you can actually tell a slight
difference in game with the wand length
but on this page right here as you can
see I'm going back and forth no change
in the wand length now what's
interesting about the wand core page is
that it actually does hint at there
being some sort of difference in the
magical properties of the wand with
Dragonheart string being known for
producing powerful magic the Unicorn
hair for producing consistent magic and
the phoenix feather for producing a
great range of magic again though I
think those options are purely there for
lore reasons and to get you a slightly
different dialogue option for Mr
Ollivander after you select your wand
and again I just have to stress these
properties here none of them can be
changed from this point forward so once
you hold down the purchase button here
there's no confirmation screen that's it
this is the one that you'll have and the
one you'll use throughout the game now
guys if you're finding this video
helpful go ahead and click that
subscribe button Bell icon on for more
Hogwarts Legacy content I really
appreciate hate the support and it
certainly helps out the channel overall
I really think this is a nice system
Avalanche has in place here that should
please the fans who all wanted wand
customization and trust me there were a
lot of people asking for this one but it
also balances that out with the lore of
the series which to anyone who's read
the books you'll know the wand chooses
the wizard we even learn in Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows that wands are
almost sentient and this magical bonding
process that takes place between the
wand and its owner is very important for
the magic of a Witcher wizard in fact
there are times in the series where
characters have to use wands other than
their own and it almost always goes
poorly Mr olivander even hints at this
with his dialogue in Hogwarts Legacy do
not be surprised at your new one's
ability to perceive your intentions
particularly in a moment of need ones
that haven't chosen their witch or
wizard simply don't perform as well this
is also one of the reasons Professor
Weasley encourages us very early in our
Hogwarts Legacy Journey to go and get
our own wand instead of using what I
assume is the loaned one at the start of
the game now there's certainly so much
to see do and explore in Hogwarts Legacy
and there are actually quite a few
things the game doesn't outright tell
you so I've prepared a list of 10 tips
and tricks I wish I knew sooner these
would have really saved me a lot of time
and you can check out that video on the
right side of your screen now as always
guys thank you all so much for watching
I'll talk to you again soon
[Music]